le président du sénat gérard larcher
l'invité de preuves par 3 bonsoir
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous pour
ce rendez-vous de public sénat avec l'
agence france-presse
trois grandes parties comme chaque
semaine et trois grandes questions pour
vous premièrement est-ce que ça va mieux
comme le prétend françois hollande
avec ce chiffre que l'on a appris tout à
l'heure 60 mille chômeurs de moins au
mois de mars dans la foulée de cette
annonce spectaculaire ce méga-contrat de
34 milliards de d'euros de sous-marins à
passer par l'australie deuxième grande
question est ce qu'on assiste à l'envol
de françois fillon votre champion qui
avait un peu disparu des écrans radar
c'est votre candidat donc pour la
primaire encore loin certes d'alain
juppé nicolas sarkozy mais son
changement de ton il promet désormais de
casser la baraque semble porter
questions sur la primaire tout à l'heure
avec guillaume daudin de la fp enfin
troisième partie des missions troisième
question est ce que le sénat fait
obstacle à la nouvelle réunion du
congrès qui avait été prévu cette fois
pour réformer le conseil supérieur de la
magistrature alors est ce qu'il ya un
changement de pied des sénateurs sur ce
sujet sur ce texte qui a été approuvé
tout à l'heure par les députés que les
sénateurs avaient approuvé même vous
répondrai tout à l'heure notamment au
ministre de la justice et avec tous ces
sujets en lien avec le sénat vous
répondrez à michael à metz de public
sénat
mais d'abord donc jarrar chez est ce que
pour vous ça va mieux comme le prétend
françois hollande qui attend comme tous
les français bien sûr l'inversion de la
courbe et là hop -1 7% au mois de mars
d'abord aujourd'hui de bonnes nouvelles
à contrat de commandes de sous marins
comme toujours il faut qu'ils soient
confirmés puisque on efface une
alternance possible en australie mais
moi je m'en réjouis
c'est le signe de l'excellence française
c'est le signe aussi d'une la qualité de
notre armée parce qu'il ya aussi l'image
de notre armée et puis celle du chômage
qui à la différence du mot dernier est
meilleur je rappelle que le chiffre du
chômage faut les juger sur la durée mais
au fond quand j'ai entendu françois
hollande
j'ai le sentiment qu'on regarde n'est
pas le même pays en fait notre pays
il se sent pas bien et on le voit dans
la rue on le voit dans les coeurs on le
voit dans les sondages
dans ce que nous entendons y est
peut-être avec ces chiffres et ces
indicateurs économiques je serai je
jouais de l'organisme souhaite pour mon
pays parce que ça conduit mon pays à
aller vers autre chose que des forces
politiques qui font partie des valeurs
démocratiques mais que je constate c'est
que nous avons sur moins de quatre ans
plus huit cent mille chômeurs de
catégorie a c'est un chiffre
incontournable nous avons une dette
une dette qui ne cesse de croître même
si les taux d'intérêt sont à zéro je
dois le dire
nous avons en plus une situation
politique où il ya plus de confiance
entre l'exécutif et du pays entre le
chef de l'état et le pays
on a une majorité fragmentée éclatée où
en fait un vrai projet politique est
remplacé par la une d'un grand magazine
on voit un ministre sa fiche est alors
que le pays souffre vous paraîtrez
l'annuel ma conjointe avec son épouse le
soir qui le soir mais sans doute c'était
pour dire que son ennemi c'était la
finance était à londres le soir au
président de la république tente de
s'expliquer devant pas là on s'attendait
relation s'arrête parce que vous venez
de fêter deux numéros là gérard larcher
vous nous dites n'y a pas de futur on a
pas d'espoir avec le pouvoir actuel non
à tout à fait à la gauche dans une
démocratie suffit pas de s'agiter y
compris à la faculté de médecine pour
avoir aidé finir un avenir je crois que
il y à un sujet majeur c'est la
confiance entre le pays
pourquoi parce que le président il s'est
engagé
il s'est engagé il ya quatre ans
notamment sur la courbe du chômage c'est
pas un mois je souhaite vraiment que le
chômage sonia parce que pour moi c'est
le mal absolu dans mon pays mais en même
temps on a une europe en crise est-ce
qu'on compte dans les négociations de
genève sur la syrie voilà des vrais
sujets je lire la réussite du président
c'est sans doute l'intervention en
afrique
si je devais en reconnaître une quand
même pas reconnaître une commun je
voudrais que mon pays à mieux oui mais
alors donc et vous allez continuer à
rappeler que au delà des variations
saisonnières du chômage or on espère que
ça va continuer à s'améliorer
vous allez continuer à rappeler que le
chômage a explosé depuis
début du quinquennat c'est donc ça que
vous allez tenir sur trail de chômage
tout le monde le sait et là je je note
que d'après les premières analyses ce
sera les entrées en stage mais
méfions-nous les chiffres mensuels
françois hollande maintient en tous les
cas son credo et il était évidemment
très heureux tout à l'heure de rendre
visite à la dcns pour célébrer ces
raisons je serais bien content alors oui
on les écoute
la france va mieux ça ne va pas mieux
pour tout le monde
à l'évidence il y en a beaucoup dans
notre pays qui souffre qui suppose des
questions même par rapport à leur avenir
et j'imagine que au moment même où on
annonce un succès de cette importance
d'autres peuvent être dans l'inquiétude
sur leur propre emploi ou sur leur
propre industrie mais faut avoir
confiance en nous mêmes j'ai évoqué
votre propre situation
il ya à peine deux ans trois ans des
doutes qui pouvaient exister et dans
beaucoup d'entreprises
et puis il y a cette capacité qui est la
nôtre d'aller de l'avant d'avoir
confiance en nous de porter de l'est ce
point
alors ce contrat pour les sous marins
australiens donc c'est un motif de
fierté pour la france pour vous aussi
vous l'avez déjà rare chez meys voilà
al'inverse par exemple de manuel valls à
ne vous rend pas optimistes pour le pays
je jalili a su plutôt une bonne nouvelle
comme on va pas ne pas la goûter comme
et les puisqu'on sait que ça aura un
effet si elle et concrétiser cette bonne
nouvelle de plus de 4000 emplois je
pense à cherbourg je pense à lorient je
pense quand je pense aux sous traitants
eux extrêmement nombreux je pense aussi
à la nécessité pour notre pays de
dégager pour son armée 2% du pib chaque
année pour que nous soyons à la hauteur
mais en même temps la question qui est
posée c'est est ce que ce pays
il a besoin de réformes il a besoin de
changer et on voit bien que c'est pas la
loi sur le travail qui va conduire à ce
changement à ce propos justement est ce
que quand il viendra ce texte devant le
sénat vous allez le rétablir dans sa
version initiale donc dans un sens plus
favorable aux angles il appartiendra à
la commission et aux commissions
concernées sans aucun doute de remettre
un certain nombre de marqueurs mais nous
l'avions déjà fait au moment de la loi
macron beaucoup
coût des propositions qui ont été dans
la première version de la loi travail
était déjà des propositions que le sénat
avait porté sur le texte macron alors on
a parlé de du rassemblement et au la
gauche
hier soir à paris vous avez parlé de la
faculté de médecine prochain meeting
prévu à lille avec l'objectif est
également de mettre en avant le clivage
droite gauche on écoute la ministre de
la santé qui était sur l'antenne de
public sénat ce matin pour défendre
cette initiative donc le réveiller la
gauche sur le thème de la fierté aussi
de les réalisations depuis le début du
quinquennat
la france elle va mieux que ne le
pensent les français il y a dans notre
pays des sources de dynamisme
d'innovation de transformation de
modernité et c'était ça la réunion
d'hier c'était non pas de prétendre que
tout va très bien dans le meilleur des
mondes possibles mais que une
mobilisation pour montrer ce qui a été
fait est nécessaire et notamment dire à
ceux qui nous font un procès en
reniement
vous vous trompez ça n'est pas vrai et
regarder ce qui a été fait alors les
ministres présents hier soir ont voulu
réactiver le clivage droite gauche donc
en contradiction avec emmanuel macron
que vous avez cités est ce que pour vous
il ya un phénomène macron dans ce pays
alors je crois qu'ils en tous les cas
une bulle mais comme des bulles de savon
un moment et faisait cap parce que
monsieur macron il doit d'abord faire
aller mieux l'économie française
c'est sa première tâche et il est quoi
qu'il en dise l'obligé du président de
la république il n'a pas tiré d'une
élection sa légitimité mais de sa
compétence aux côtés du président de la
république
quand j'entends la ministre je pense sur
la médecine de molière vous savez je
vais mieux je vais mieux mais finalement
est-ce que je vais aller mieux
ça fait penser aussi aux cas briller au
général de gaulle quand on parlait
d'europe
est-ce que là qu'on peut rester au
gouvernement selon vous aujourd'hui
auquel il appartient au président de la
république de prendre de décision mais
je dois vous dire que je suis quand même
étonné à moins qu'il y ait une forme de
publicité que je n'ose imaginer un
gouvernement saluait une équipe et dans
cette équipe
nice traduira moderne vers l'instrument
des chefs de l'état mais je pense qu'il
a d'abord besoin d'être autour du
premier ministre
c'est comme ça que je conçois une équipe
gouvernementale
vous avez évoqué le climat de
contestation générale dans le pays ne
retombe pas puisqu'il y aura une
nouvelle journée de mobilisation jeudi
contre la loi travail alors que la cgt
je sais bien ce que vous suivait de très
près toutes les questions syndicales
gérard larcher en tant qu'ancien
ministre du travail notamment la cgt a
montré le visage de la radicalisation
lors de son congrès récent à marseille
en écoute philippe martinez nous notre
référence parce que sinon on va pas s'en
sortir c'est pas le moins disant social
parce que bientôt on va nous comparer à
qui le modèle social indien ou du
bangladesh c'est ça la référence donc à
baisser les droits des salariés en
france s'est donné un mauvais signe est
ce que ça vous inquiète cette
radicalisation de la cgt non pas d'abord
le mieux disant social c'est celui qui a
des taux de chômage comparable allemagne
ou à l'autriche
voilà et des vrais comparaison est ce qu
ont satisfait de la situation
d'aujourd'hui d'avoir 25% des jeunes
hors de l'emploi
est ce que c'est ça être le mieux disant
social je dois dire qu'il faut qu'on
change de registre
sur ce sujet quand chances de logiciels
y compris moi même par rapport à des
conceptions que je pouvais avoir
il ya 12 ans aujourd'hui mais il faut
faire confiance dans l'entreprise
vous avez évolué vos mains vous évoluez
en je considère que c'est d'abord dans
un rapport de confiance avec
l'entreprise que seules entreprises
créent la richesse et donc l'emploi
en même temps il faut des stabilisateurs
sociaux le temps est venu j'avais fait
un rapport en 2007 sur ce sujet qui
marquait mon évolution
d'ailleurs je l'avais fait avec la
commission européenne sur la nécessaire
flexibilité la nécessité du dialogue
dans l'entreprise et en même temps de la
sécurisation des parcours professionnels
des salariés
alors vous avez vous plaidez il ya un
instant pour des grandes réformes qui
sont nécessaires dans le pays est ce
qu'elles seront possibles en 2017 si
l'alternance dans un pays si éruptif oui
si on lui dit ce qu'on va faire
et si on fait ce qu'on a dit c'est
l'averse de ce qu'on vit depuis quatre
ans il tout autre chose dedans
l'actualité etc la question identitaire
qui peut-être sera au coeur de la
campagne de 2010 est en tous les cas
manuel valls en parle beaucoup et il met
en garde contre certaines dérives et je
crois que vous
rinié sur ce point gérard larcher
écouter céline pina qui est une ancienne
conseillère régionale ps du val-d'oise
qui pointe la menace islamiste dans
beaucoup de quartiers
une menace qui est dirigée contre des
populations abandonnées dit elle cet
abandon des populations favorise le rôle
prescripteur pour le coup aux temps des
salafistes que des frères musulmans se
sont pas des terroristes dire quel est
le passage à l'acte sanglant n'est pas
forcément inscrits dans leur stratégie
en revanche il prépare le basculement de
ceux qui choisissent de passer à l'acte
parce que leur vision du monde et leur
vision de la société est exactement la
même et parmi les premières choses
auxquelles ils vont s'attaquer ça va
être l'égalité femme homme est un des
instruments les plus fortes pour le
faire c'est le voile ce qui aujourd'hui
est dangereux c'est qu'on abandonne des
populations entières dans certains
quartiers et ne sont plus travaillés que
par ses messages politiques là ça
devient la norme
voilà propos recueillis par un jardin de
bavois l'eau et vous vous même vous avez
des craintes
écoutez que sur les exécutifs locaux qui
pourrait basculer gérard larcher il ya
un an
j'écrivais au président de la république
souvenez-vous la nation un héritage en
partage après les événements dramatiques
de janvier il avait sollicité claude
bartolone il m'avait sollicité pour une
réflexion et je lui disais que le pire
des dangers étaient le repli
communautaire dans ce pays je voyais il
y avait d'autres facteurs mais celui là
et je crois que 1 du sujet c'est d'abord
en dehors d'identité c'est qu'est ce que
nous voulons faire de la république est
ce qu'il ya une communauté nationale et
dans cette communauté nationale
l'affirmation qu'il n'y a pas d'autres
constitutions que la constitution de la
république quand on voit un certain
nombre de textes issus des frères
musulmans ont dit la charia notre
constitution bien non je pense qu'il ya
un islam tout à fait compatible avec les
valeurs de la république j'aurais pas
parler de celui qui vous ayez un peu
moi je parle aussi de celui qui avec
lequel la république est compatible et
puis assurer qu'ils sont pas dans les
valeurs de la république et la 6è
république tout simplement de s'exprimer
la république l'a fait il ya 110 ans en
1905 parce qu'elle a fait preuve de
lâcheté certains élus lomé nous est
clairement ces dernières années mais
nous sommes tous nous avons tous parfois
démissionner nous avons tous parfois
démissionner devant certaines atteintes
notamment l'égalité hommes-femmes et
vous craignez effectivement que des
islamistes prennent le pouvoir local
ainsi le sont élus par la voie de la
démocratie dans un certain nombre de
territoires
eh bien il faudra qu'à république
réaffirme que on ne transige pas avec
les valeurs de la république
ça c'est un message qui dépasse les
clivages gauche droite jean marie le
guen a dit il ya quelques jours le
ministre chargé des relations avec le
parlement comme que vous connaissez bien
a dit qu'aujourd'hui dans notre pays la
république n'allait plus de soi pour
tout le monde c'est un constat que vous
dressez également gérard larcher elle
peut ne pas aller de soi pour
quelques-uns et bien moi je vous
réaffirme que la république a le devoir
de défendre les valeurs républicaines et
d'être intransigeantes cette république
sur ses valeurs parmi lesquelles la cité
des principes d'égalité hommes-femmes
les principes de liberté
les principes d'état de droit qui
doivent l'emporter et il n'y a pas de
lois religieuses quelles qu'elles soient
je vais mes propres convictions qui soit
supérieure à la loi de la république
on est bien sûr là au delà du clivage
droite gauche et on est au delà de la
seule question de l'islam est-ce que
vous avez été choqué par la journée du
voile à sciences po la semaine et je me
méfie de toutes les provocations et les
prosélytisme c'est vrai parfois dans le
cadre de certains voiles qui sont portés
et qui sont mes retrouver mon rapport
tous âges a écrit un an et je le dis
clairement attention à jouer avec un
certain nombre de concepts la république
elle traverse aujourd'hui une période
difficile et notre devoir et ne pas
jouer avec les boîtes d'allumettes
je crois que c'est important je crois à
une seule communauté nationale et cette
communauté nationale elle doit être
capable d'assimiler c'est le mot du code
civil n'en ayant pas peur
manuel valls et évoque beaucoup cette
question il d'autres identitaire
d'ailleurs il ne redoute pas le mot 1
vous le soutenez alors qu'il est lui
critiqué sur ce point là vous le savez
pas par une partie de la gauche croit
qu'il nous rappelle les valeurs de la
république etc sont des valeurs qui
départ seul à seul clivage gauche droite
je le dis
nous avons ensemble à bien commun et qui
s'appelle la république c'est peut-être
une répétition ce que je fais mais ont
une communauté nationale et son appli
communautaire c'est le plus grand des
dangers qui nous traversent ce sera un
des enjeux de 2017
ce sera un des enjeux de 2017 et des
années qui suivent
car il faudra du courage pour conduire
qu ont résisté notamment un fait
par exemple il ya plus d'enfants
français de confession israélite dans un
certain nombre d'écoles publiques est-ce
que vous croyez que c'est acceptable est
parti à man où la rue henri seine saint
denis c'est ce que dénonce
seine-saint-denis a eu d'autres endroits
quand je vois des compatriotes de
confession israélite
vous parlez de partir je trouve ça pour
ma part inadmissible dans une république
qui doit protéger chacun des siens
quelle que soit son origine sa race son
histoire et ses convictions
deuxième partie de preuves par 3 avec
guillaume daudin donc de l'agencé france
presse qui va nous rejoindre pour
évoquer les primaires de novembre et la
remontée de votre champion en françois
fillon un bond de 2,5 points il a doublé
son score à 15 %
l'analyse d'abord des douars de jérôme
sainte-marie sondeurs et politologues
françois fillon des forces spécifiques
on sait que son livre par exemple a très
bien marché en librairie peut-être que
aussi où les sympathisants de droite ça
qu'ils ont encore du temps avant de se
décider
eh bien le rate
et fluctue selon les moments il ya eu un
moment sarkozy ou un moment super d'être
comme vivons mais surtout très récemment
peut-être que là ils veulent
s'intéresser un petit peu à françois
fillon je pense qu'il ya un petit jeu si
vous voulez du sympathisants de droite
avec les sondages actuellement
bonsoir bonsoir vos questions gérard
larcher soutient donc de françois fillon
et voilà et justement ces derniers temps
françois fillon a décidé de me cogner un
peu plus contre ses rivaux dans divers
sondages il a regagné quelques points il
est repassé devant bruno le maire alors
on lui aurait dit ça je croyais à il ya
cinq ans alors à étonner mais qu' il dit
qu'il soit derrière maintenant il est
devant à nouveau
vous pensez qu'il ya quelque chose qui
repart pour lui je pense que d'abord la
primaire elle est en train de se mettre
en place dans la tête de nos concitoyens
et que chacune et chacun de nos
concitoyens en âge de voter qui se
retrouvent dans les valeurs du centre et
de la droite républicaine va avoir envie
de s'exprimer en or était la preuve par
3 fin d'année dernière n'aura dit est ce
qu'il y aura une primaire je vous
réponds oui on a des bureaux de vote
on a les listes électorales depuis
vendredi on a un guide électorale et la
commission d'organisation près des
primaires dont je suis membre
peut-être avec un statut de sage
intérieur casques bleus certes non non
non ça c'est une invention de fin de
semaine surveillez les dérapages comme à
mende avec un sarkozyste un gp il ya une
haute autorité de la chose qui compte
c'est que les primaires vont avoir lieu
qui aura un débat aura du projet que ça
commencera ce débat au mois de septembre
de manière formelle d'accord avec des
débats dans les médias et que d'ici là
il est naturel que chacun des candidats
fassent valoir ou vend lui s'il est
déclarée pour cette candidature
son projet ses idées c'est ce que fait
françois fillon c'est ce que fait alain
juppé c'est ce que fait bruno le maire
comment expliquez vous donc que
justement ces derniers temps il arrive
un peu plus à sortir de la nasse dans
laquelle il était un peu en ferry je
sais pas mais
on voit d'abord pas du tout mais on voit
qu'il ya de nombreux parlementaires le
soutiennent c'est assez révélateur
alors qu'il n'était pas au mieux de sa
forme sur le baromètre et les sondages
il s'est trouvé beaucoup de parlements
forme d'assises et une assise parce
qu'il a aussi un projet solide mais il y
aura un certain nombre de parlementaires
qui soutiendront alain juppé et d'autre
mais je crois que la primaire je veux
qu'elle réussisse je veux que à l'issue
d'un débat y ait un projet que le 27 au
soir ce sera une de mes responsabilités
soyons tous rassemblés derrière celui ou
celle qui sera choisie est ce que vous
pensez qu'elle françois fillon que
coiffer tout le monde sur le poteau
je sais pas parce que moi vous savez je
suis un homme de chevaux de course
d'origine et je ne vous dit jamais qui
va gagner le prix de l'arc de triomphe
mais en début de saison alors je crois
que c'est soixante douze parlementaires
qui ont annoncé leur soutien à monsieur
fillon justement dans une liste qui l'a
dévoilé récemment et il manquait
quelques soutiens très connue est le
vôtre notamment b ne manquera pas mon
truc qui est à même de le soutenir en
province mais le statut particulier
c'est d'ailleurs le cas de bernard
accoyer le signe que nous avons à
l'intérieur de la commission nous sommes
là pour être des hommes aussi de
rassemblement d'accord les hommes d'
équilibre ce qui n'empêche pas que moi
je chemine avec françois fillon je ne
cesse de le répéter bien longtemps avec
philippe seguin alors en tous les cas on
l'a entendu l'ancien premier ministre
prône une réelle rupture radicale et
bien du coup pour jean marie le guen
cela représente pour la france un danger
on écoute la ministre et evo réagissait
dans la radicalité quand j'entends
monsieur fillon parlait de dire qu'il
veut casser la baraque
la baraque en question c'est notre
modèle social il y a des gens qui vont
prendre comme méthode politique
la rupture violente en 2017 qui pour
mettre à bas notre modèle social pour
mettre à bas des règles républicaines
alors correction
moi je vais vous reparler de l'état de
la baraque faisons l'inventaire plus de
10% de chômeurs 25% de jeunes au chômage
c'est ça l'état de la baraque même si
elle va si bien la baraque
c'est vrai qu'il faut pas la cas c'est
ce que dit monsieur latreille 2100
milliards de dette au 30 juin prochain
alors c'est sûr gardons la baraque
ce qu'on propose c'est vraiment un
changement d'accord le disais tout à
l'heure et en répondant aux questions de
votre confrère je disais tout à l'heure
il faut vraiment changer de logiciel
d'accord il faut retrouver le chemin
vers le plein emploi vers la croissance
nous avons une croissance en berne dans
notre pays et il ne suffira pas même si
je m'en réjouis commandes de sous marins
ou de rafale et il faut retrouver ce
chemin de la croissance et la baraque au
faut aller en train de s'effondrer sur
la france il faut plutôt construire une
nouvelle maison dans l'est dans les
divers quand il ya toujours des échanges
d'amabilités chez chez alain juppé on
commence à entendre qu'en fait le
programme de françois fillon c'est celui
d'un outsider c'est à dire qu'il est
tellement radical qu'en fait ils
seraient irréalisables et qu' il ya des
mesures qui sont proposés par exemple il
veut supprimer
vous vous dites si je m'égare 600 mille
fonctionnaires en cinq ans c'est à dire
ne pas embaucher un seul fonctionnaire
en cinq ans et on nous dit à nous
journalistes qu'en fait c'est pas un
programme réaliste c'est pas un
programme de quelqu'un qui veut
gouverner tous les cas si on mai 2010
est un projet construit depuis bien
longtemps
et avant même que les sondages ne le
mesure c'est un projet qui peut encore
et à débattre
moi par exemple je suis sur certains
aspects un peu moins libérale que
françois fillon tout le monde le sait
tout le monde sait que je contribue à
apporter un certain nombre d'éléments d'
équilibre avec d'autres je pense aux
politiques d'aménagement du territoire
je pense à la dimension de la ruralité
je pense à ce que la france ne se résume
pas à quelques métropoles quelques
régions puissante et je sais que ces
idées aujourd'hui françois fillon les
reprogrammant mettait en garde contre un
certain de coupes budgétaires
non
le met pas en garde contre le retour à
l'équilibré djeddah sûr mais c'est la
méthode de retour à l'équilibré
budgétaire qui doit se faire d'une
manière progressive mais volontaire
parce que aujourd'hui quand même dire
les choses
les promesses du président de la
république c'est quoi 4 milliard de
dépenses en plus d'un mois qu'il dit un
grand journal économique hier vont
s'ajouter 3 milliards pour edf
7 milliards comment les finances dans
une situation de déficit et de déficit
j'allais dire par rapport aux
engagements européens c'est ça la
réalité et donc pas voir des candidats
qui s'engagent dans la vérité avec le
courage c'est ce qu'attendent les
français et français ils veulent plus
entendre - président il veut l'entendre
que doit devenir la france avec le
projet que je propose est ce que dit
monsieur fillon c'est tout un tas de
coupes sèches net et massimo pause et
vous paraît surréaliste et d'évaluation
budgétaires qui sont significatives mais
comment voulez vous redresser le pays
qu'est ce qu'a fait schoder en allemagne
alors à guillaume daudin nous a rapporté
des propos entendus donc dans les
milieux juppé voilà voilà bien serait-ce
que quand même vous êtes inquiet de la
tournure que pourrait prendre lui-même
ou pas du lait ou pas du tout parce que
c'est logique
alain juppé avec sa personnalité ses
qualités et c'est un homme d'état il
peut avoir une approche différente de
celle de françois fillon sur la méthode
mais l'objectif est le même redresser la
france lui faire retrouver la croissance
redonner confiance demain dans une
france mais 5 afin de divulguer
d'exporter de reconstruire une europe
parce qu'aujourd'hui on est face à une
europe qui s'interroge crise des
migrants briques site interrogations
d'allemagne sur la politique de la
banque centrale européenne
eh bien je dois dire que c'est au
contraire de ces idées là que nous
allons faire une vraie proposition
voilà pourquoi le 27 celui qui sera
choisi se rapportera la foi de son
projet mais de la richesse du projet
dont ils auront débattu tous ensemble et
dans la sambre les primaires il est
écrit que chacun des candidats
s'engagent à soutenir mais aussi à
participer à la campagne du futur
gagnant vous pensez qu'on aura
après la primaire une belle photo de
famille avec noé anciens candidats non
la photo de famille que j'entends c'est
un pack 1 gagner pour la france d'accord
mais pour gagner en mai et pour jouer
l'alternance
alors moi je suis dans une vie très
antérieur et jouer au rugby
je veux bien est un des piliers du pack
il ya certains des candidats à cette
primaire geoffroy didier ou nathalie
kosciusko morizet qui disent que en fait
elle est allée un peu verrouiller cette
primaire nathalie kosciuko morizet dise
est en fait c'est sarkozy juppé fillon
le maire qui veulent faire la primaire
entre eux et il n'ya pas d'accéder dans
une autre à cause des parrainages et
parce qu'on ait adopté des statuts
parce que la primaire est une chose
sérieuse et qu'il est logique qu'on
entend dans la primaire un peu comme
dans le processus des présidentielles et
donc on a adopté depuis je crois même
que certains d'entre vous votez ses
statuts au bureau politique eh bien on
les respecte
on fonctionne avec des règles on
fonctionne pas avec des humeurs leur
candidature à la candidature est
légitime ou illégitime mais le moment
nul râler candidat eh bien les combien
selon vous faudrait être cinq ou six je
pense mais ah oui mais c'est savez je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure pour le prix
de l'arc de triomphe et méfions nous des
pronostics à l'avance et là je pense que
oui il ya eu même fait d'être autour de
six candidats le fait qu' un nombre
illimité de par l'issue les républicains
bien sûr mais le fait qu' un nombre
illimité de parlementaires puissent
soutenir un candidat au final ça bloque
la candidature par un nombre illimité
ça voudrait dire que la droite et le
centre est il là j'aurais donné
l'argumentaire saab a un peu échappé
jusque là illimitée dans l'allier en blé
le nombre de partis ou d'hommes et c'est
très simple vous avez à peu près de 100
députés républicains
une trentaine de centristes vous en avez
ici 144 républicain vous avez 44
centriste
quelques jeunes inscrits voilà le vivier
dans lequel aujourd'hui peuvent
chez les candidats ouais euh pas piocher
retrouver leur confiance et être
ceinture utile ou puéril justement de
montrer ses muscles à travers un nombre
record de parrainage comme françois
fillon l'a fait d'ailleurs en annonçant
ses 72 non et en attendant le vote en
septembre
c'est autre chose pour ce fillon il
démontrait à l'issue d'un processus de
construction d'un projet que est un
moment qui n'était pas évident pour lui
au lancement de sa campagne qui avait
lieu à paris auxquelles j'ai participé
et bien qu'il avait un nombre de
parlementaires qui se retrouvaient
autour de son projet il n'était pas là
uniquement comme des fans qui ont
participé à la construction de son
projet et qui ont envie de le faire
partager au pays alors dans le comment
dire dans la plupart des sondages et
enquêtes d'opinion actuelle c'est
clairement marine le pen qui est
pronostiquée comme la future candidate
qui à laquelle sera opposé le candidat
des républicains
comment vous faites chez les
républicains pour vous préparer à ça
qu'est ce que l'équipe juppé sort un
livre bientôt % pour s'attaquer au
programme économique du front national
est-ce que vous commencez à cibler des
arguments a essayé de regarder ce
qu'elle fait bruno retailleau un groupe
de républicains au sénat
il ya maintenant trois mois et demi ils
ont sorti un ensemble de documents qui
démonte les propositions économiques et
sociales d'ailleurs du front national
démontrant leur impossibilité démontant
le mensonge qu'il porte c'est sur le
terrain dron prix désiré le terrain des
idées et du combat d'accord c'est
d'ailleurs ce que la majorité
sénatoriale à la fois des républicains
nos amis centristes dans les
propositions qui vont être faites dans
les semaines et les mois qui viennent
vont construire aussi leur part de
projet pour l'alternance et combattre
marine le pen c'est d'abord parler la
vérité pas aligné lors des six peut être
parler la vérité proposer des voies et
moyens pour conduire au résultat car ce
qu'ils vont faire marine le pen est ce
qu'ils adhèrent aux idées de l'extrême
droite pour beaucoup non mais ils ont le
sentiment qu'on a déjà tout essayé
la gauche et la droite voilà pourquoi
qu'on marisol touraine où monsieur le
guen 10 la gauche et la droite ce n'est
pas pareil
oui c'est pas pareil c'est peut-être
mieux que ça peut être des gens qui ont
voté par la condition que ce soit la
gauche républicaine
le centre et la droite républicaine et
c'est pas pareil et c'est très bien que
ça fait l'idée d'une recomposition
politique ne vous effleure pas à vous
parce qu'on sait que c'est une idée qui
est prêté à manuel valls et même alain
juppé l'évoquent il évoque une
possibilité d'ouvrir aussi la majorité
un monsieur rentre mais qu'est-ce que
vous quel est votre avis là dessus rien
n'empêche de s'ouvrir
oui je ne crois pas que l'armée position
ne crois pas l'ouverture à quelques
personnalités
il peut y avoir des projets et un
président de la république qui propose
un projet aux pays qui puisse être
partagée au delà du clivage entre
majorité et opposition
il peut y avoir des sujets de cette
nature général de gaulle l'avait bien
lui pour redresser notre pays en 1958 et
pourtant c'était un homme chacun
reconnaît qu'ils avaient des idées très
claires il a cette capacité là françois
fillon justement à pouvoir proposer des
pensions rassembler comme alain juppé
peut rassembler puisque vous citiez ces
deux noms peut être tous les deux ils
ont dit qu'ils étaient clairement
candidat ya non vous n'avez pas cité
depuis le début de cette émission c'est
nicolas sarkozy n'est pas encore
candidat certes mais est ce que pour
vous il est un bon président il est
encore dans la course il a bon président
de république je vous le dis et chacun
sait ma liberté ton à son égard et il
permet le débat il permet aussi énorme
en aucun moment entravé la préparation
des mets ce qu'il serait un bon candidat
mais je pense à président de la
république il a les qualités pour l'être
vacanciers français refusent de rejouer
ce match on le savait
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui ils n'ont pas
envie du même match nous verrons au
moins de ventes
est-ce qu'il est pas un peu comme
françois hollande nicolas sarkozy l'un
des responsables de la désaffection des
français à l'égard de la politique par
les promesses qui ont été faites et qui
n'ont pas forcément été réalisés nicolas
sarkozy a eu à corbeil la grande crise
de 2008 à gérer il a plutôt bien géré et
c'est vrai que les français n'ont pas eu
le sentiment des résultats qui avaient
été les engagements de 2007
mais entre temps la crise était passé et
que peut-être sur un certain nombre de
sujets je pense à la réforme notamment
de la tva tva sociale nous n'avons pas
été au bout d'un engagement qui a été
pris et nous l'avons fait trop tard mais
il nicolas sarkozy le reconnaît lui même
est ce que vous pouvez influencer le
programme de france accueillant sur une
thématique par exemple fiscale est-ce
que vous par exemple vous êtes pour la
suppression de l'impôt sur la fortune
sera leur chef qui est c'est fait un
mauvais 1 pour nous mais par exemple je
pense que c'est l'occasion ou jamais de
repenser à une idée qui peut apparaître
pour certains ancienne que la
participation ou l'intéressement
pour redresser pas un pays sans que
chacun en tire des fruits aussi bien les
salariés que les chefs d'entreprise
c'est cette vision que j'ai de la
société donc ça c'est le gaullisme
social qui parle et qui continue à
penser que c'est une idée singulièrement
moderne pour rassembler le pays j'ai
envie de rassembler mon pays
d'accord et est ce que vous pensez donc
une dernière fois que twitter vous
répondiez pas exactement des à la
question que françois fillon a vraiment
les chances de remontée de coiffer sur
le poteau je pense que tout est jouable
point jure un quatuor de tête qui ce qui
serait un peu voilà il n'y a pas encore
le premier violon si vous voulez
d'accord et nous verrons dans le quatuor
à cordes qui sortira mais l'important
après c'est qu'ils jouent ensemble et
c'est ce à quoi je travaillerai dire
vous aviez encore une question le traité
transatlantique
oui sur le traite transatlantique tout à
fait il ya eu ces derniers temps tout un
tas de déclarations au sein du
gouvernement disant que ça allait être
compliqué de signer ce traité si un
certain nombre de garanties n'étaient
pas respectées sur le lait par exemple
les appellations d'origine contrôlée
est-ce que
vous vous pensez que c'est une erreur du
gouvernement de ceux de reculer sur
cette signature des choses d'abord le
sénat travaille beaucoup sur ce sujet
vous avez déjà eu deux rapports de la
commission pour l'union européenne et un
rapport de la commission des affaires
économiques et que sur ce sujet j'ai moi
même de demander à ce qu'on ait une
analyse en profondeur
ce que je constate c'est que la hausse
il axe franco allemand ne fonctionne pas
si c'est un des grands d'allemagne est
plutôt françois hollande de traité nous
voyons que aujourd'hui un axe germano
américain sur ce sujet
absolument et et et qu'il n'y a plus
d'accès franco-allemand et il n'y aura
pas d'avenir à ce traité
si on ne reconstruit pas autour d'un axe
franco allemand
là encore il n'ya pas que la question
des ogm il n'y a pas que la question des
appellations d'origine protégée et l
impact sur la vie sur la viande bovine
il n'y a pas que les sujets d'arbitrage
je pense que nous avons intérêt à
construire un traité qui nous permettent
de re nation est ce qu'on peut continuer
à faire que ce soit les états unis et y
compris le congrès américain y compris
les banques américaines le trésor
américain qui nous impose notamment
regardez ce qui s'est passé pour le
crédit agricole ou la bnp donc nous
avons intérêt à normaliser nos relations
avec les états unis comme nous l'avons
fait avec le canada panneaux ne peut pas
être aux dépens d'europe et ça ne peut
pas être un accord partiel
et ça se construit les 28 mai notamment
les pays fondateurs et notamment autour
de l'axé franco à l'allemagne a l'air
plus favorables aux positions
américaines que ne l'est la et bien il y
aura pas de traité dans ces conditions
là je vous le dis et s'il n'y avait pas
entre la france et l'allemagne
la dimension de la confiance autour de
se prêter n'y aura pas de traité merci
guillaume daudin troisième partie de
près par trois avec michaël szames s de
public sénat
et cette question est ce que le sénat
fait obstacle à la nouvelle réunion du
congrès prévu cette fois pour réformer
le conseil supérieur de la magistrature
les députés ont voté tout à l'heure
cette réforme que le sénat avait adopté
gérard larcher c'était en 2003
vous y étiez favorable comme le rappelle
en permanence le ministre de la justice
jean jacques urvoas qui espéraient une
adoption au congrès tous les sénateurs
de droite gérard larcher en tête bruno
retailleau en tête ont voté ce texte et
ce texte a été voté par la droite en
1981 18 je veux montrer que quand on dit
qu'on est favorable à l'indépendance de
la justice et qu'on ne vote pas ce texte
alors et c'est ce que christian jacob
dire aujourd'hui dans le figaro il dit
la phrase je souhaite maintenir les
liens organiques entre la chancellerie
et le parquet disant autrement on veut
caporaliser le parquet c'est à dire qu
on est nostalgique d'une justice aux
ordres
cela veut dire que christian jacob le
choisir les juges qui plaisent au
pouvoir politique
voilà l'accusation est assez forte mais
qu'elle avait souvent soir sur la
justice donc le ministre de la justice
l'a dit cet après-midi après l'adoption
à l'assemblée nationale la voix du
congrès est ouverte
est ce le cas je sais pas si la voie du
congrès ouverte mais la voix de
jean-jacques urvoas a singulièrement
changé depuis 2013 puisque à l'époque je
rappelle qu'il considérait que le
travail qui avait été fait par une
majorité sénatoriale à ces diverses
à cette époque là était tout à fait
insuffisantes et ne coupez pas le droit
de changer on voit le dit chancellerie
il a changé comme moi moi je n'ai pas
changé je pense que ce qui avait été le
fruit des travaux
je pense notamment de jean jacques hyest
à l'intérieur de la commission des lois
des réflexions aussi de michel mercier
sur l'avis conforme ne coupent
d'ailleurs pas le lien entre la
chancellerie et les nominations seront
prises après la chancellerie et le
parquet mais que l'avis conforme c'est
la pratique qu'on a depuis un certain
nombre de maisons de garde des sceaux
nous dit pas s'il y aura un congrès ou
pas c'est pas moi c'est le président de
la république alors est ce que le
président la république peut faire un
ersatz de réformes constitutionnelles
souvenait le sujet avait été évoqué
est-ce que ça mérite de convoquer le
congrès
votre amour du monde dans je ne suis pas
certain que ça le mérite aujourd'hui
puisque la pratique n'est pas en
distorsion moi si ça vient encore et je
le voterai à titre personnel donc les
choses sont claires je le voterai attire
sans que vous rejetez tout procès
d'intention du ministre de la justice
je ne souhaite pas de procès d'intention
je vous donne mon vote jeudi que le
projet de mise la justice a évolué mais
je considère qu' il appartient au
président de la république de décider ou
non s'il convoque le congrès je
considère moi c'est votre avis je
considère que la réunion du congrès
n'est pas opportune aujourd'hui c'est
votre avis personnel pour d'autres comme
vous avez donné votre vote les députés
ont voté contre
ça veut dire que là il ya un flou et
quand il ya un flou il ya un autre les
députés et les sénateurs oui pas floues
il ya eu un vote en 2013 par un groupe
ump à l'époque auquel j'appartenais je
ne change pas mon vote jeudi que la
réunion du conseil ne paraît pas
opportune d'accord si le président de la
république mais c'est à lui qu'il
appartient de décider car s'il réunit
sous l'eau ou non le congrès mon vote
vous le connaissez ça c'est clair qu'est
ce que vous répondez à l'accusation du
ministre tandis que la droite alizés
week a paralysé la justice et yves ldd
pro core tout seul c'est des mots et que
ceci est un peu ce que veut nicolas
sarkozy prononcé des mots excessifs sauf
un boyau
rappelons nous qu elle était le projet
de madame taubira c'était le
corporatisme du conseil supérieur de la
magistrature
puisqu'il s'agissait de donner la
majorité aux magistrats mais la gauche a
beaucoup reproché à nicolas sarkozy
certains vers la page de marleau du
texte parlons pas nicolas sarkozy
je vous parle du taq qui a reproché à
michel mercier d'avoir été un garde des
sceaux qui n'est pas respecté
complètement ni le parquet dé la
magistrate magistrature du siège
personnes comportement michel mercier
comme garde des sceaux a été exemplaire
président de la république s'appelait
nicolas sarkozy il ya une réunion cet
après-midi à matignon autour du
terrorisme
il ya certainement eu des vocations
autour de l'état d'urgence est ce que
vous savez quand aura lieu
le vote sur l'extension de l'état
d'urgence au sénat le 10 mai a priori
nous aurons la prorogation de l'état
d'urgence et personnellement je soutiens
cette prorogation fait de l'euro et est
interdit et du tour de france
mais l'état d'urgence ne saurait être un
état permanent et en même temps je me
christiane est ce qu'on est en état
d'urgence et qu'on laisse le déaut être
pris de force est occupé est-ce qu'on
est en état d'urgence et qu'on laisse
ici ou là je ne parle pas de
manifestations légitimes syndicales
organisées les nuits de la nuit debout
continuer leur violence peut pas y avoir
deux régime de l'état d'urgence
l'état d'urgence est un état
exceptionnel par lequel il nous faut
garantir aussi la préservation des
droits et vous savez que senna est
extrêmement attentif non peut pas
réclamer d'un côté l'état d'urgence et
l'essai de l'autre côté la chienlit ça
veut dire donc que le gouvernement
aujourd'hui n'agit pas aux fonctions par
rapport à l'état d'urgence qui est
actuel aller à 100 mètres du sénat sur
vous verrez si c'est l'état d'urgence
c'est le cirque sépare et à ions
certains comme je rampe est encore
nicolas sarkozy avait parlé de chienlit
à l'époque vous reprendrez seulement la
rue du général de gaulle vient de le
reprendre et vous estimez que vraiment
c'est à l'échelle du pays que cette
chienlit s'est installée noblement à la
règle car il lui pl je prends cet
exemple oui on est à cent mètres du
sénat et regarder ce qui se passe
est-ce que c'est appliquer état
d'urgence
donc vous demander des gestes ferme du
monsieur intérieur que les français sont
égaux face à l'état d'urgence at à lire
ce genre de bagarres la relation est
lâché par lou interdire ces
manifestations comme celle de nuit
debout par exemple il faudrait dévaluer
inter ne peut pas continuer à tolérer
derrière chaque nuit debout ya des
violences et vais pas aussi quand même
cette impression qu'on ne sait pas
sortir de cet état d'urgence aujourd'hui
nous sommes dans une situation
exceptionnelle la menace est très élevé
et dans la situation dans laquelle je
suis je sais que c'est élevé que c'est
pas des propos
qui seraient les propos circonstanciel
et face à cette menace élevée
il n'empêche qu'il va falloir un moment
sortir de l'état d'urgence organiser le
pays pour faire face de manière
permanente au risque et en même temps
retrouvé l'état de droit dans sa
plénitude
parce que l'état d'urgence suspens une
partie quand même des libertés comment
fait-on pour sortir de cet état
d'urgence est une question
d'organisation et c'est ce que conduit
actuellement le ministre de l'intérieur
il nous tient informés
il est d'ailleurs ce que fait le premier
ministre c'était jean claude gaudin qui
cet après midi me représenter à cette
réunion
moi même je suis avec beaucoup
d'attention et je recevrai dans 48
heures d'ailleurs et membre éminent
charge de du suivi des pourparlers de
cette réunion où les parents dire plus
non cuse et moi l'important ce
d'efficacité de la sécurité vous évoquez
la sortie de l'état d'urgence pourtant
la menace terroriste elle est toujours
la même elle n'a pas changé mais vous ne
pouvez pas rester en permanence en
l'état d'urgence il faut qu'à un moment
le pays s'organisent pour s'installer
face à une donne de risque qui est
différente
d'accord tout cela ne vous donne pas des
regrets quand on vois l'échec de la
réforme constitutionnelle où vous devez
inscrire l'état d'urgence dans la
constitution
ça aurait pu être une façon aussi de
sortir dignement de cet état d'urgence
et qu'il y ait un cadre non il ya un
cadre des lois de 55 donc le cadre il
existe fallait-il constitutionnaliser la
réponse le sénat l'a donné clairement le
gouvernement s'est pris les pieds dans
la sphère de la déchéance de vous en
avez dit c'est ce qui nous arrive
aujourd'hui assumer son incapacité
d'avoir pu conduire avec sa majorité
les engagements du président de la
république à versailles chacun se
renvoie la balle est ce qu'il vous en
tient rigueur non exécutif aujourd'hui
envoyé
le pardon c'est le président de la
république lui bon bon et vous ont
renvoyé la balle à manuel valls et vous
dit où vous jouez à 2017
y a que ça qui vous intéressent non pas
du tout j'ai simplement dit que le sénat
avait ligne rouge qui aurait pas d'
appât tribu alors quand même pas
scandale de dire à un homme de gauche
qui depuis les valeurs de gauche qui
depuis 1922 se bat contre la patrie de
leur rappeler quand même et que c'est un
combat qui mérite quelques quelques
respect alors l'accusation effectivement
un homme qu'elle est venu de la gauche
on vous avait accusé de jouer en fête
2010 est l'alternance et vous
personnellement c'est le sénateur ps luc
carvounas qui vous accuse de manquer
d'impartialité gérard larcher lors des
questions d'actualité on l'écouté vous
allez pouvoir lui répondre
d'ailleurs gérard larcher hier était
extrêmement virulent a coupé le micro de
tout le monde donc c'est pas non plus ma
conception de l'animation de l'hémicycle
gérard larcher coup plus vite le micro
quand il s'agit d'un orateurs de gauche
que de droite et il est beaucoup plus
cool sur le timing et le chrono quand il
s'agit d'un orateurs de droite que de
gauche
il suffit de regarder ce qui se passe
votre réponse totalement faux j'ai fait
un petit statistiques que j'ai rapporté
ya trois semaines en conférence des
présidents
la différence entre socialistes et
républicains
ces 52 centièmes de seconde pendant
trois mois
vous rendez compte monsieur carvounas et
sensible c'est un sprinteur et même les
communistes ont dépassé de 8 secondes
16 les écologistes de 7 secondes pour
vous rendez compte
en messieurs carvounas il faut qu'il
reprenne son chronomètre d'hier a lâché
pour rester un petit peu sur ces
questions d'actualité dabo sur les
réformes qui ont été amenés au céda il
ya eu ce droit de réplique qui est
arrivé est ce que ça a changé
fondamentalement la donne des questions
d'actualité au sénat
je pense qu'il ya deux choses c'est que
chaque semaine nous nous retrouvons pour
des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement et que donc il commence
quelque part y avoir un rendez vous avec
une partie du pays autour des questions
d'actualité au sénat que ce soit le
mardi
et la semaine suivante le le jeudi c'est
aussi je crois le sentiment que le sénat
est au travail et on le voit dans
l'application tout simplement des règles
de fonctionnement qui sont maintenant
rentrer dans tous les esprits avec une
valorisation du du travail du du sénat
je sens dans le pays mais et c'est
partager et d'ailleurs nous voyons bien
ce d'ailleurs ça bénéficie à public
sénat
et nous avons des audiences chi chi chi
mods avons plus de 320 mail abonnée à
twitter
notre cité est incroyablement fréquenté
tout ceci nous amène dans une meilleure
rencontre avec le pays et je dois dire
que les sénateurs majorité comme
opposition ont cette rencontre plus
forte me semble-t-il avec le pays c'est
en tous les cas ce que je ressens que je
ressent très fortement y compris par
rapport à la masse des changes que je
peux avoir avec les nos compatriotes
vous ce président il ya deux cas de
déclaration mensongère devant des
commissions du sénat
ce sont deux cas bien distincts on va
bien faire la distinction celui de
michelle d'objets qui est un célèbre
pneumologue au sujet de l'impact du
diesel sur la santé celui de frédéric
oudéa ancien président de cas à l'époque
de la société générale pour une affaire
de paradis fiscaux le sénat at il était
bafouée à tous les cas que la procédure
soit engagée
c'est légitime c'est légitime parce que
venir devant une commission d'enquêté et
s'exprimer sous serment c'est quelque
chose de sérieux c'est même quelque
chose de symbolique et que donc quand on
aime les enfants disant 'tiens je ne
qualifie pas la faute nous verrons une
fois les procédures
la procédure se déroule en bureau du
sénat va donc examiner
à la suite d'une nouvelle audition café
d'ancien président monsieur husson
l'ancien rapporteur la magie du
professeur oublier claude bérit-debat
rapportera devant le bureau
qu'est ce qu'il m'avait xavier peu
risqué mais ce n'est pas ce qu'il peut
risquer c'est plus simplement que bureau
décide ou non de transmettre protard de
la république un genre procureur et
concernant le président de la société
génère alors on est sur un sujet assez
comparable qui a été rappelé je le
rappelle les rives mans par les
révélations de panama peppers sur les
parts des fiscs oui tous les programmes
et la commission des finances gilera
plus cet après-midi en place cet après
midi la commission des finances est dans
son rôle quand elle procède à un
contrôle qu'elle va procéder à un
contrôle
en même temps l'ancien président de la
commission denquête monsieur dominati a
souhaité entendre monsieur oudéa et
ensuite ils ont la capacité de saisir le
bureau qui examinera suivant la même
procédure
au mois de mai et quelles sont les
conséquences pour monsieur oudéa lors le
communiste alain bocquet lui demande la
saisie du bureau immédiatement un dès la
16ème avec des sanctions peut être allez
on va l'écouter à l'invoquer aurait
préféré répondu j'espère que vous
entendrez l'approvionnement j'ai appris
dans la bouche de monsieur larcher
président du sénat que monsieur o dia
serait auditionné le 11 mai prochain ce
qui est une bonne chose maintenant créer
les conditions pour que cette audition
débouche sur la vérité parce que moi
j'ai simplement mis en regard les
déclarations de monsieur diop faites
sous serment le 17 avril 2012 et les
révélations faites par l'epa damas
papers il ya un hiatus entre les deux à
l'évidence saura-t-il sous serment parce
que c'est important ça qu'il a menti
sous serment il aurait menti sous
serment
sera-t-il alors il sera pas sous serment
à risque donc ils vont induire de
l'agglo mission d' enquête
mais la présidente de la commission et
je ne doute pas monsieur dominati et
monsieur évoqué me feront part de leurs
sentiments et je vous soumettrai ensuite
pour instruction au bureau donc fait une
procédure est d'ailleurs monsieur bloqué
vient de reconnaître qu'il ne fallait
pas à faire dans l'immédiat valises
donné les délais nécessaires savez on
est sur des matières qui nécessite à la
fois la vérité
solidité et on n'est pas sous la pulsion
par contre il est de mon devoir de faire
que devant une commission d enquête du
sénat
quand on parle sous serment
on dise la vérité et rien que la vérité
quand vous l'avez vécu tout cela à titre
peut-être personnel vous qui habitez par
le sénat mais je pense que c'est le
sénat qui joue parfaitement son rôle
vous voyez on ne considère pas que les
affaires passe comme ça que ce soit sur
la sphère de la santé publique ou la
faire de l'éthique financière
le sénat est dans son rôle et dans sa
fonction de contrôle
et voilà je dis toujours que le sénat a
une responsabilité particulière dans le
contrôle et vous voyez que le contrôle
nous l'appliquerons alors qu'avez vous à
dire aux accusations d'une association
qui s'appelle démocratie directe qui
accuse députés et sénateurs et même vous
même d'avoir touché ce qu'on pourra
plaider des suppléments de rémunération
d'indemnités supplémentaires
d'abord je dis attention hein attention
tout ça relève ce devrait être ma
conclusion d'un âne antiparlementarisme
qu'on cultive et je dis aussi attention
journalistes je le dis avec respect mais
de répondre ce genre de choses sans
avoir vérifié au préalable d'ailleurs je
n'ai reçu que deux jours après la lettre
de monsieur lebreton méthode résidence
est associé et ensuite j'ai pu lui
répondre une base légale 1947 une base
légale parce que quand générale de la
sécurité code de la sécurité sociale
cg contrôle de la cour des comptes et
comparaison avec d'autres parlements je
pense à l'allemagne le royaume uni y
aura des sens des choses qu parra j'ai
fait la réponse à monsieur lebreton
j'ai vu qu'ils sont pressés - d'être sur
les ondes pour expliquer la réponse que
je lui avais fait monsieur bartolone
je crois qu'il faut simplement faire
attention attention à
l'anti-parlementarisme dans ces temps de
crise c'est facile mais c'est dangereux
pour la télé quand les candidats de
droite tous demandent moins de
parlementaire et c'est autre chose on
parle de réformes
oui je ne dis pas que la procédure
parlementaire ne doivent pas être
réformé
j'ai moi-même dans la réforme du sénat
est proposé et ça fait partie d'ailleurs
des propositions que je viens d'envoyer
au président de groupe à la suite du
travail de monsieur karoutchi d'alain
richard est ce qu'on me donne pas un
temps de commissions et un temps de
séance un peu différent pour aller plus
vers la péta bien merci merci merci
messieurs le président du sénat merci à
tous bon soir à trèves et à la semaine
prochaine